everything i know about cooking i've
learned through hard work drive and
passion from the age of 17 i made food
my life and it's fair to say that since
then food has been the making of me but
the sort of cooking i made my name with
intricate dishes made with the world's
finest ingredients is a million miles
away from the food i grew up on
for the first program in the series i'm
updating some of the home-cooked dishes
i absolutely adored when i was a kid
first up for breakfast at classic from
my childhood stunning baked beans with
fluffy potato cakes
next a modern take of my favorite
childhood lunch fantastic fish fingers
and an irresistible chip buddy my mouth
is salivating
and i've got competition in the kitchen
as mum helps make dinner dad shouldn't
manny be doing the cousin because she's
the better cook excuse me when i was a
kid this is my dream dinner super
comforting shepherd's pie with peas and
carrots followed by a steamed date
pudding with butterscotch sauce to die
for let's get this show on the road
this is my ultimate childhood food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day easy homemade spicy fake
beans with deliciously light potato
cakes
[Music]
the first big thing
that i remember as a kid was
bacon
and beans
so this is like a little rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear
go and chase some mice now panel get
nice and hot i'm gonna turn these beans
into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly
season that it's cured so it doesn't
need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're somewhat bland so
i always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so
a nice finely chopped chili
with
the seeds
chili in
now a little bit of garlic
crushed
phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chilli
and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across
then cut down to simply dice
bacon onion chilli garlic
that flavor all contained in that little
pan
once you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken
and enrich as well at the same time
that looks beautiful
now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan
it's got that really nice powerful kick
to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasonings
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
passata puree tomatoes
turn that down
simmer the sauce to reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein and
have a lovely soft texture
turn down the heat
and let the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery
potato heaven take a nice
spoon of potato lightly flour your board
we're gonna fry these
crisp
on the outside and just
nice and fluffy in the center
now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil
into the pan
put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown
gently
turn it
over love that nice light crisp
they look beautiful
now take them out
oh
potato cake in the middle and a nice
beautiful
spoon
of beans
growing up with beans on toast as a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude
for beans especially cooked like that
[Music]
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes comfort
and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you more the
food that made me the man i am
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
shop for to make my ultimate lunch and
dinner
starting with pollock
i grew up on whitefish like cod and
haddock but today i'm using pollock
whitefish like pollock has a wonderful
sweet firm flaky flesh
pollock's so versatile
bake it batter it cook it up in fish pie
or even cut it into strips for my fish
fingers which i'm cooking for lunch
growing up i ate tons of lamb mince meat
it's generally from less expensive but
tasty cuts like neck and belly
you can use lamb mints in so many ways
in middle eastern copters or mixed with
mint for a twist on a traditional burger
but as a kid i couldn't get enough of
shepherd's pie and i'm making an amazing
version for dinner
i ate potatoes almost every day as a kid
i love them but remember it pays to use
them properly
they come in three types flowery waxy
and all rounders
for mash fried or roasting flowery
potatoes like king edwards are brilliant
for boiling or salads use waxy potatoes
like charlotte
[Music]
if you want the best of both worlds in
your kitchen go for an all-rounder like
desiree
i'm using them to make incredible oven
chips next
when i was growing up food in britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you couldn't
even buy avocados in the shops where i
lived paris kitchens might have been
cooking nouvelle cuisine but it
certainly hadn't made any inroads around
our way moulton my lunch when i was
growing up was very plain
pretty trashy but i still love it now
and again fish fingers with a delicious
chip butty
the secret
of a good chip butty
is in the
potato
now these are desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist
simply peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain
season
and cover well with propeca
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that
next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock a really nice firm
delicious
fish
got the fish in finger size batons of
fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish it firms the
fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little bit
more durable especially in the pan now
for the coating start by thoroughly
coating the fish in seasoned flour
and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then it stops those corners
almost burning in the pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is dill goes brilliantly
well with a fish
and run the dill through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
and a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the dill
nice and carefully
take them out
they look and smell incredible
stay nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with button thick crusty bread
[Music]
a slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavour
on
slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship butti there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food but
my god that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for one moment when you
wanna stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
when i was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
let's get this show on the old town
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed eight pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now
i'm gonna sieve the flour would you i'll
chop here sean chop those dates please
that was a favorite wasn't it amazing
sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't this themed
and everything was sort of steam you had
jam roly-poly poorly
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant so it helps cut that
richness to the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe
yes looks fantastic on the table
and then treacle
cheek it in
oh look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please
thank you they'll do and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if i pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yep
thank you
nice
nice and slow
don't go too fast
you see i always used to think that it
was an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me
tumbling around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the ball didn't you all the time
now
lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat i think i was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is to keep that nice and
tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh hey push my hand
come on
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you gonna wash up court
one
oh dear goodness
do you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on
whilst mum forces me to break the habit
of a lifetime dude that's the thought
you're washing up it does that to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite
shepherd's pie what's the secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
grown in it
so we're going to use leeks
and onions and then start browning off
the mints you know no color no flavor
i've never forgotten that you know that
yep
so
good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks sick greasy
and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheaper nasty let me clear
your peelings now
all right thank you very much there's no
nails in there now is there no
don't be chicken i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back
no sometimes they complained that there
was no
come on no i'm telling you
you never ever got a complaint no
how long do you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six years
oh hello chilly
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you chop our onion please
daddy yeah oh gosh your eyes are going
to water
daddy what's in this spot sorry
in there we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
um how do skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their phone i'm
not too sure on the scalabone i'm just
gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called
under 12. who won
the depends who's the fastest cat one
two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
tells why do you make a nice cup of tea
for honey you want me to disappear
thank you bye so give that a little fry
off okay mm-hmm
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse oh
she's certainly having a bit of fun
worcester sauce that's gonna give that
really nice spicy
seasoning oh thank you oh that's hot you
okay yeah
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
i'm just gonna put a little touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm going
to make it nice and rich
okay
reduce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your mints
with your stock
now i'm gonna bring it up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like a little taste yes please
is it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it will be delicious
trust me now gorge spring onions we'll
chop up
and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes it's going to sit on
top of that nice nicer i like that
savory yeah delicious mince that's laced
with all that red wine nice so is into
there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello jack have a
nice day school yeah oh yeah yeah
so we'll dry out those potatoes and then
mash them no oh can i mash them would
you okay um holly slice a little knob of
butter in there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cook
exactly that
no really
you used to help me as well
right you kids do
no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want them little
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just want to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you on the door people
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it
and then the carrots
seeded coats that's why i didn't put
carrots in let's put them on the side
i'll see last job before serving pour
that gorgeous butterscotch sauce over
the pudding
okay i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steamed date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
are family megan jack tilly holly hello
now take a seat live digging it i'm good
let's play something guys so now this is
your recipe
this is nan's recipe but modernized mum
how is that it's very nice but i can't
taste the wine no that's right i said
give it a chance to cook out nunny wow
that's amazing did you like it tills
yeah man you did a good job excuse me
none of these recipes
revamped feeling that you might have
been sitting
[Music]
you still didn't do the washing up there
are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you